I'm about to eat a food that I have not
eaten in over 20 years that's not by
choice this food was discontinued about
20 years ago much to my dad's dismay I'm
talking about Mohawk Valley brand
Limburger cheese spread which was
distributed by Kraft and leaf for some
reason unknown to beö or my dad in the
past Kraft decided that this item was
not popular Limburger cheese was
invented early in the 19th century by
monks who lived out in Limburg that's
not a lie I'm not lying
random wall I'm staring at think you're
gonna sass me Waldo I'll get you to eat
you
the rose in popularity in the early
nineteen hundred's in America when it
came over here and it even surpassed
Swiss cheese in terms of popularity it
was very popular in the German
populations much like New York and
Cincinnati however during the
Prohibition apparently Limburger cheese
could not be eaten without an
accompanying beer so it lost popularity
this is all true this is all true all
true now what I have here is not Mohawk
Valley brand Limburger cheese spread
this is Amish country old fashioned
Limburger pasteurized processed cheese
spread the real stinky stuff
I'm not joking that's that's what it
says the real stinky stuff now if you
don't know Limburger cheese you may have
heard of it it's the cheese that smells
like feet and this spread is something
that I cherished as a child my dad ate
this probably because he was German and
it's kind of a German thing you know
weird food but I liked it you know I
really really liked it as a kid and I
haven't had it just because it wasn't
available so this people online have
said tastes similar this only came out a
few years ago and there's a small but
very energetic portion of the internet
that is kind of missing the old
Limburger cheese spread I am kind of
that hyper person and my dad's go-to
snack was Triscuits and Limburger cheese
spread
love this my dad got mad at me because I
ate all the jars were only ever like
this big and sometimes it was a big one
and this Dez was in that big around that
big that's it these I had a special
order from Wisconsin which is the mecca
of cheese if you didn't know I love
cheese don't mention that I really love
cheese but I have not had this in ages I
don't know what kind of here's okay food
memory is a real thing
food triggers very specific memories it
can be one of the most like throwback e
foods it makes you go back in your brain
it make you go back way back in your
past it makes you think a long time ago
if you get food that you not eat for a
while you get big brain and then you
remember you must like smells so I have
not opened this I've had this for about
two days now and I've been looking at it
and I'm like I really want to eat it but
I don't know if it's gonna be the same I
don't know if I'm gonna remember it the
same way I don't know if I'm gonna hate
it but if it's even anything close to
what I remember as a kid I honestly
don't know I I really I don't know how
it's gonna affect me yeah yeah risking
cardboard cut your yeah yeah I'm at risk
in addition to I forget I stopped eating
Triscuits at the same time because why
else would you buy a Triscuit nothing
against Triscuits but what's the point
good and so long that's delicious
she already like already I'm kind of
getting this rush back I I took one bite
of that I was taken back to my childhood
home the first one I remember in
Cincinnati I just remember like for some
reason right now all I can think about
is sitting in or standing in the middle
of the kitchen in there just I can
remember the smell of the walls we have
like old-style wallpaper so it had a
very distinct smell to it and then we
eventually stripped it off of me at this
like that wood paneling on the walls
they're the kind of fake wood
weird that's crazy okay anyway this is
the coup de Gras it looks the same by
the way it looks much the same that
smells exactly the same
Prabhas it smells like Limburger and
it's super stinky I don't hate it
which is a good sign and that's crazy
for some reason I just remembered
sitting in the garage whittling a horn
down this is a very strange memory to
come back to it because it has nothing
to do with Limburger cheese my dad used
to make old-style
musket rifle muzzle loaders that you had
to do they're handcrafted out of wood
and my dad needs to making them and he
used to make powder horns which
literally just bull's horns that you
shaved down for gunpowder and you put
them the muzzle and that's it I used to
to try to press this bandit I used to
sit in the garage and I used to just
whittle down the Horde it was horrible
horrible horrible but I did it because
you know I wanted to be involved so I
just sit for hours with a nail a big old
file like a huge one like a footlong
just like on this horn and it was never
enough it's not it's not it doesn't
smell quite the same and I remember the
the other spread being a big goo beer
but maybe because this one's more
substantial no maybe it's got more
flavor to it that's crazy this is where
rubber meets the road this is like just
doing it's so weird
picking something up that you haven't
done in 20 years and doing it again like
this was my after-school jam like I
would like I'm not gonna make it like I
ate it every single day but I
loved this it was delicious
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that is weird um not the taste it tastes
exactly the same I don't know why I'm
like that's really I like as soon as I
took a bite I started tearing up and I
don't know why I just like as soon as I
took that bite I was taken back just
every the only time I had it was in that
house only I grew up and I have this
weird like question of memories that are
popping up I remember this one time my
dad was pissed off I don't know why this
is coming up my dad was pissed off
because the alarm was going off the fire
alarms going off and he he was really
frustrated about something so he just
[ __ ] jumped up and I think that's the
thing is just like this this is such a
my dad thing and for the longest time my
dad was pissed off because they didn't
make it anymore for some reason he
scoured the internet for it my dad was
always very tech savvy so he was on the
internet long before I was he introduced
me to computers and so he would scour
the internet I bet on some obscure
cheese forum that's still in existence
to this day is a post made by mine
[Laughter]
that's incredible I love it
who could we do it's really good you
want it's really good yeah for those at
home you know obviously there's no
YouTube smellivision Limburger it's
smell is very strong and very distinct
and this isn't even accurate Limburger
cheese this is liver ger spread which is
different than straight up cheese so if
anything this is like a mild
introduction to Limburger as a whole and
I may not like the cheese straight up
but I love this
I remember my dad told me I couldn't
ride my bike through the backyard cuz it
tore up a lawn so what did I do
a [ __ ] road but like one lap around
the backyard no I was looking in the
windows like you can see you know he
can't see him in then I rode through
real quick and then I came around for
the second lap have like and then I look
in the window and he's just standing in
the glass doorway just very slow that's
so weird
yeah god I don't know it's really really
weird this is a very specific food and I
doubt that anybody would like it if you
want to try Limburger spread I'll put a
link in the description it is most
likely a purely acquired taste so if you
didn't grow up with this you may not
like it and they take a while for you to
become a customer but if you like soft
stinky cheeses I think the trick it's
the only thing that brings it back I
don't know I don't even have the words
to describe how I'm feeling right now
I'm very nostalgic about my dad right
now like I don't think about my dad's on
a daily basis but you know he was
probably you know the best dad that I
could have hoped for you know for those
of you don't know something you may not
my dad passed away when I was 18
and he was just a really good dad that's
all he ever wanted to be was a dad and
he had me and my brother when he was
very old in life he had my brother when
he was 46 47 I bet if you tried this he
would say it's not the same to me
Kraft bring back Mohawk Valley brand
limburger's red but this is good this is
really good
I'm not joking about it I'm legitimately
like this is pretty good pretty good but
you know this probably horribly
dangerous for me so I also bought this
this is a Geiger counter so this
measures radiation for those of you
don't know so little uh it's got a big
old screen is a little baseline okay
that's low I think good cheese is not
ready maybe can you go get your new
dishware sorry old dishware pre-world
War two yeah I got this yeah yeah it's
relevant yes relevant you anytime a
Geiger counter is relevant you gotta
know what you're safe
look I got this because Amy got these
new dishes and you never know when you
want to check the radiation of something
is that 13 these that okay this is fine
okay this is pottery from when the 1930s
this is a lottery from the 1930 before
the war
nothing right it's totally fun right
very good very good
yeah very good first thing first this is
also from lending a 1930 same badge okay
you see the it's not shooting little
sparks of radiation as she flares to my
eyes from the neutrons okay it's it's
peeking up over 1,200 if it's over a
thousand very high leave the area a ship
and find out why mm says extremely high
evacuate immediately report to
government and its it's just crossing
1500 Amy it's going up
this is evacuate immediately oh it's up
over 2200 that's evacuate immediately
and report to the government level I
this is it 14 microsieverts not joking
yeah but now it's in context take away
[Music]
Hellmuth I'm going to check the spot
that it was on
my hat like Chernobyl fell no no it's
not funny
it's not funny anyway that's not the
point in this video but it's a good
sidebar it's a good be plot to this book
so this is another food that I've had
more recent than 20 years ago but I
haven't had for probably about 10 years
now the radiation anyway so this was my
dad's favorite snack Fig Newtons
you want to know confirmation that my
dad was at one point an old man he loved
himself a Newtons
so this is just like this is the coup de
Gras is my dad's two favorite snacks of
all time was Limburger spread Triscuits
and Fig Newtons so I'm just gonna have
to complete off the memory I'm gonna see
where this one takes me because the last
time I had this was it not in my first
child at home but the one after my dad
met my stepmom good good they're good
stuff they're really good stuff and
they're not too terribly bad for you
yeah they used to be bigger I mean
there's really nothing else to say about
this I just I really like Fig Newtons
marching band
two different minded me a marching band
oh my god not marching man like on the
field marching but the era in which I
was doing marching band that was crazy
it's not as like a visceral kick in the
brain as Limburger was but this is
pretty good
delicious they're like nutrigrain bars
but cut up into thirds
very good if you've never had a Fig
Newton and you want to [ __ ] real good
try full fiber the prunes no they're the
same thing if burn is just a fig right
oh wait no this doesn't have a lot
Harbor Oh am I crazy
are there dead wasps and figs are there
female wasps no they need to get inside
a fake to lay their eggs so the
chromosome of male and female dicks are
trying to do that the female wasp
burrows inside the faith through a
narrow opening if she arrives in a male
thick she's able to lay her eggs in an
ideal environment and then dies male or
female so yes there is a likely at least
one death wasp inside of things I would
like to eat okay great okay in
conclusion if you like me you Steve
Mohawk Valley brand Limburger spread
this is a adequate substitute it's not
the same that it's very likely that the
original will never come back unless we
all cumulatively tweet at Kraft and
demand scream rant rave and never stop
tweeting at them until they bring it
back I'll just move on and maybe try
this and hey if you guys manage to try
this and you've never tried Limburger
spread film it send me the video
because I want to see that since the
reactions to eating this right here I
love this this is amazing it is good
enough in my mind to bring back the
memories of the times when I ate it as a
kid
I know it'll wear off eventually but I
really like the fact that every time I
take a bite of this it makes me smile
cuz I remember like my childhood and I
didn't have a great childhood because I
was so poor you know we had to eat a
Limburger cheese but no oh yeah I had a
great childhood and that's largely
impart to my dad because he was just
such a good dad
well anyway that's all for now if you
got other foods that you want me to
review let me know down in the comments
below thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always we'll see you in
the next video bye